[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're discussing witing governments
across the world now we've all heard of
the ministry of magic and most of you
should hopefully be privy to the
existence of the magical Congress of the
United States of America but have you
heard of the Argentinian Council of
magic how about the burkinabe ministry
of magic I didn't think so while the
ministry of magic and the Magical
Congress of United States of America are
undoubtedly well-known entities to Avid
Harry Potter fans The Wider realm of
magical governance spans far beyond
these prominent institutions today we're
going to embark on a journey across the
globe to shine a spotlight on the
magical governments of all 26 countries
in the Wizarding World unveiling the
rich tapestry of Unique Systems
fascinating customs and captivating
histories that govern the hidden
societies of witches and wizards
globally let's dive in andoran Ministry
of Magic the andoran ministry of magic
is a small and secretive organization
nestled In the Pines mountains its
structure is known for its emphasis on
communal decision-making and consensus
Among The Wizarding Community with a
focus on environmental preservation and
magical creature protection the andoran
ministry in to maintain Harmony between
Wizards and nature often drawing
inspiration from ancient magical
practices rooted in the regions unique
Traditions though unconfirmed it's
likely that the andoran ministry HQ is
near the Whiting School bobor which can
also be found in the Pyrenees
Argentinian Council of magic known for
its vibrant magical Community the
Argentinian Council of magic takes a
decentralized approach to governance
comprised of regional Representatives
this Council Fosters strong regional
identities and traditions and focuses on
cultural preservation magical education
and Regional magical creature
conservation the Argentinian Council of
magic is well known for its involvement
in hosting the 2014 quiddit World Cup
after much deliberation the ceremony
ended up taking place in the Patagonian
desert the Argentinian council's
president at this time was a witch by
the name of Valentin Ina
Vasquez Bangladeshi Ministry of Magic
the Bangladeshi Ministry of magic is
renowned for its commitment to both
magic and muggle relations operating
from its headquarters within the ancient
city of Dara the ministry promotes
coexistence cultural exchange and
tolerance between magical and
non-magical communities one noteworthy
aspect of Bangladesh is that they viewed
the game of quiddit with suspicion this
is namely due to the fact that they had
a flourish in trade in flying carpets
rather than
broomsticks Brazilian Ministry of magic
founded in 1697 the Brazilian Ministry
of magic is a vibrant and Lively
institution reflecting the country's
Rich magical Heritage operating out of
its headquarters in Rio de Janeiro's p l
the ministry celebrates the diversity of
wisting culture and ancient magical
practices like the British Ministry it
oversees a variety of departments in
including the department of magical
creatures ensuring the preservation of
unique Brazilian magical creatures such
as Kora and kurup pirz the Brazilian
Ministry is notably thrust into light in
the third installment of the Fantastic
Beast franchise the secrets of
Dumbledore in this film we see Brazilian
Minister for magic vicencia Santos Run
for the office of supreme mugwamp of the
international Confederation of wizards
she eventually becomes Supreme mugwamp
after being being chosen by the chillin
the Brazilian Ministry was also known
for hosting the international warlock
convention a fact that's briefly
mentioned in the daily Prophet Bulgarian
Ministry of magic located in the
Enchanted city of Sophia the Bulgarian
Ministry of magic Embraces a traditional
and hierarchical structure ruled by a
minister for magic named o blanks this
ministry places an emphasis on magical
law enforcement International magical
cooperation and magical
education true to the nation's strong
quiddit tradition and reputation the
ministry also places great importance on
the regulation and support of the
renowned Bulgarian Quidditch team the
tri was a tournament hosted by
durmstrang Institute located within
Bulgaria highlights the ministry's
involvement in fostering international
wisting relations the Bulgarian Minister
for magic is notably introduced to Harry
Potter by Cornelius fudge during the
final match of the 1994 quidditch World
Cup O blans seems excited when he
recognized Harry scar serving as an
indication to Voldemort's Global
relevance burin Ministry of Magic the
Burkin Ministry of magic situated in the
bustling city of wagadugu prioritizes
the preservation of ancient magical
traditions and the harmonious
integration of magic within binab
Society the ministry is known for its
strong ties to the local magical
communities and traditional healers with
a focus on supporting magical education
and advocating for the welfare of
magical creatures the burkinabe ministry
strives to maintain a balance between
Magic and the natural world in fact this
ministry had to render several forests
unplottable in their country for the
sole use of the Run Spore a magical
three-headed snake native to their
country as run spores are quite easy to
spot even by Muggles this measure was
put in place to help preserve the
international statute of
secrecy Chinese Ministry of Magic the
Chinese Ministry of magic headquartered
in the mysterious city of Beijing boasts
a rich magical history deeply
intertwined with traditional Chinese
culture its governance is rooted in a
structured and disciplined approach
ensuring strict adherence to magical
laws and
regulations the ministry places strong
emphasis on maintaining secrecy and
preserving the balance between the
Wizarding and non-magical worlds in 19
1932 the Chinese Minister for magic Lu T
also ran for the office of supreme
mugwamp of the international
Confederation of wizards however he is
not selected by the Chillin losing to
Brazilian Minister vicencia Santos
French Ministry of magic fortunately
there's quite a lot of info on the
French Ministry nestled in the heart of
the magical community in Paris the
French Ministry of magic founded in 1790
during the French Revolution sets itself
apart with its emphasis on beauty
elegance and finesse known for its
Exquisite magical artifacts and
avanguard magical research the ministry
takes great pride in its enchanting
contributions to the Wizarding Arts and
Sciences located in the grounds of PL
deur found in the sixth district of
Paris the ministry HQ could be accessed
by Wallace Fountain which served as the
visitors entrance the French ministry's
motto was
in meaning cast Bewitched conjured much
like the British Ministry of magic this
governmental institution was broken up
into many different dep departments or
bureaus including the buau dece magic
comparable to the Department of magical
law enforcement the buau de magic
communic responsible for Magical
communication including the regulation
and management of enchantments charms
and other means of magical messaging the
buau desor serving as the head
headquarters for the auras of France
this division focuses on capturing
dangerous criminals and maintaining Law
and Order The Bu Des Gast magic
dedicated to matters of magical
Gastronomy this Bureau explores the
intersection of culinary arts and Magic
fostering Innovation and creativity in
the field and the b a catasto magic
similar to the Department of magical
accidents and catastrophes this
department handles the management and
response to magical accidents and
catastrophic events it's also worth
noting that the French Ministry of magic
had a spell that stopped witches and
wizards being able to disapparate on
their premises German Ministry of Magic
the German Ministry of magic exemplifies
efficiency order and precision and
demonstrates a Ministry structure
prioritizing bureaucracy and meticulous
recordkeeping it takes a pragmatic
approach to governance focusing on
maintaining magical Law and Order
rigorous spell regulation and the
integration of magic into non-magical
Industries the German Ministry is also
renowned for its Advanced magical
research and Innovations in 1932 during
the events of the secrets of Dumbledore
German Minister Anton Vogel also held
the office of supreme mugwamp of the
international Confederation of wizards
at this time the German Ministry had
been largely infiltrated by the
supporters of grinder worldd including
vogle himself the German Ministry is
Infamous for condemning prisoners to its
visiting prison the urag which is home
to a bloodthirsty Manticore Indian
ministry of Magic the Indian ministry of
magic located in the bustling magical
city of Mumbai Embraces a vibrant and
diverse magical Community known for its
Rich mystical traditions and ancient
magical practices the ministry focuses
on promoting cultural heritage education
and the protection of magical creatures
endemic to India it also plays a crucial
role in maintaining Harmony between the
magical and non-magical communities
striving for coexistence and cultural
understanding one notable law upheld by
the Indian ministry was the Prohibition
of using the snake summon spell by
Wizards known as snake Charmers who used
it to profit from Muggles this law was
put into place because of the risk snake
charming posed to the international
statute of Wizarding secrecy intern
Confederation of wizards assigned to No
Country in particular the international
Confederation of wizards also known as
the International Federation of warlocks
is a Wizarding intergovernmental
organization that plays a vital role in
uniting the magical Community across the
world often compared to the United
Nations in the Muggle world the
Confederation serves as a platform for
Magical governments to collaborate and
address Global issues the organization
is led by a supreme m mugwamp with the
first appointed Supreme mugwamp Being
Pierre
bonicord however bonac cord's
appointment was contested due to his
stance on stopping troll hunting and
advocating for rights for trolls The
Wizarding community of lonstein which
was facing trouble with troll
communities refused to attend the first
conference causing difficulties for the
Confederation throughout history the
international Confederation of wizards
has played a crucial role in maintaining
the international statute of wizards in
secrecy which ensures the secrecy of the
wisting world from Muggles they have
added Clauses to the statute outlining
the responsibilities of each wisting
governing body and the consequences for
any breaches in times of Crisis the
Confederation has taken action to
protect the magical Community for
example they called an emergency meeting
in response to the magical disturbances
related to G grindal and they pressured
makusa to extradite grindal to Europe
overall the international Confederation
of wizards acts as a global Authority
promoting cooperation maintaining
secrecy and addressing challenges faced
by the magical community on an
international scale Iranian Ministry of
magic nestled in the ancient magical
city of Isfahan the Iranian Ministry of
magic upholds a strong bond with its
mystical Roots Guided by Council of
respected magical Elders the ministry
focuses on preserving ancient mag iCal
knowledge facilitating dialogue between
Wizards and magical beings and
safeguarding the country's Enchanted
artifacts with the rich history of
alchemy and potion making the ministry
actively supports magical research and
education fostering a thriving magical
Community Italian Ministry of Magic the
Italian Ministry of magic aka the Mino
de magio Italiano located in the
enchanting city of Rome is renowned for
its Grandeur and style
the ministry reflects the country's deep
appreciation for art and Aesthetics with
magical architecture and spells adorning
its premises it oversees a range of
departments including the department of
magical culture and the department of
magical law enforcement playing a vital
role in preserving Italian magical
Heritage and establishing magical Law
and Order the ministry organizes
numerous cultural events and magical
competitions making Italian magic
vibrant and celebrate
Japanese Ministry of Magic the Japanese
Ministry of magic hidden within the
bustling city of Tokyo embodies a unique
blend of ancient tradition and modern
Innovation with a deep respect for
ancestral occult practices the ministry
harmoniously integrates them with
Advanced magical technology it places
significant emphasis on the study of
magical creatures Exquisite want
craftsmanship and maintaining the
secrecy of the wisting world the
ministry actively supports the
development of magical Arts such as
origami based spells and hosts annual
competitions showcasing unique Japanese
magical talents the ministry plays a
crucial role in upholding the Japanese
Wizards code which consists of a
combination of legal guidelines and
social ethics this code prohibits the
practice of dark magic and sets the
standard for Behavior within the
Wizarding Community lonstein Ministry of
magic
although small in size the lonstein
ministry of magic located in the
picturesque town of Vu is known for its
efficient and meticulous approach to
governance the ministry focuses on
preserving magical Traditions unique to
lonstein and protecting its natural
magical Landscapes as of 2014 the
lonstein minister for magic was Otto OBM
another world leader in attendance of
the 2014 quiddit World Cup magical
Congress of the United States of America
makusa as the governing body for The
Wizarding community in the United States
makusa operates today from its
headquarters in the Woolworth Building
within the magical city of New York
founded in 1693 the creation of mausa
was a direct response to the Salem witch
trials and to the introduction of the
international statute of secrecy since
then they've been responsible for
maintaining the statute within the
diverse and vast American magical
Society throughout its history makusa
has faced various challenges and had to
relocate its headquarters multiple times
it had no cooperation with the nomag
government due to the Hostile
relationship between magical and
non-magical people in America in
response to a major breach of the
statute of secrecy caused by Dorcas 12
Trees makusa enacted rapaport's law
which enforced strict segregation
between Wizards and non-magical
individuals similar to the ministry of
magic makuza has a wide variety of
departments spanning all manners of
magical or other issues these include
the body for protection of magical
species the department of auras the
department of magical law enforcement
the department of no match
misinformation the department of
unidentifiable magical objects the
department for confiscated items the
Federal Bureau of covert vigilance and
no mag obliviation the makusa
surveillance Whiting resources
department the magical cleaning
Department
the major investigation department the
office for magic relations and education
and The Wizarding resources department
there's so much info on makusa that it
probably deserves its own video for that
reason I'll stop here Ministry of magic
Great Britain all right I'm not going to
dive into this one too much if you don't
know anything about the British Ministry
of magic well I'm not sure which books
and movies you've been digesting formed
in 1707 the British Ministry of magic is
the the main governing body of the
magical community of the United Kingdom
and Ireland it was created to preserve
magical law within Great Britain and
represent these countries to the larger
Wizarding World Its formation came as a
direct result of the previously created
Wizards Council prior to 1707 the
Wizards Council was the longest serving
though not the only body to govern the
magical community in Britain after the
imposition of the international statute
of secrecy in 1692 however
The Wizarding Community needed a more
highly structured organized and more
complex governing structure than they
had hitherto used to support regulate
and communicate with a community in
hiding this of course led to what is now
known as the ministry of Magic the
headquarters for the British Ministry of
magic is located well beneath his
Majesty's treasury building in central
London deep underground witch as and
wizards employed by the ministry can
enter by flu Network or apparition
like makusa there's enough info on the
British Ministry for an entire video
which J actually made for more
information just check out my video
history of the ministry of magic linked
down below Mongolian Ministry of Magic
the Mongolian Ministry of magic hidden
within the vast and breathtaking
Mongolian landscape embodies a deep
respect for nature and the spiritual
connection between Magic and the land
the ministry recognizes and honors
mongolia's ancient shamanistic tradition
incorporating them into magical
practices it plays a central role in
protecting the country's unique magical
creatures such as the elusive Mongolian
death worm New Zealand Ministry of magic
situated in the enchanting city of
Wellington the New Zealand Ministry of
magic is dedicated to preserving the
country's magical Heritage and
protecting its breathtaking natural
landscapes the ministry emphasizes
sustainable magical practices and
magical creature conservation it also
actively supports the integration of
Maui magical Traditions fostering a
strong sense of cultural identity within
the magical community in fact the
ministry's headquarters houses a
collection of early Maui art depicting
white Wizards on broomsticks it's
believed that these May depict members
of a 17th century expedition of European
hubologists playing quidditch as
observed by indigenous Mai tribesmen
Norwegian Ministry of magic hled in the
mystical city of Oslo the Norwegian
Ministry of magic Blends ancient magical
Traditions with a modern and Progressive
approach to governance the ministry
plays a vital role in preserving
Norway's Rich folklore and mythical
creatures including trolls and hras
similar to V it promotes magical
Education and Research particularly in
fields such as WLW and spellcraft the
ministry also has a strong focus on
diplomacy and cooperation with magical
communities of neighboring countries
Pakistani Ministry of Magic the
Pakistani Ministry of magic located in
the vibrant city of Islam Abad reflects
the unique blend of cultural richness
and mystical Traditions found in the
country the ministry is dedicated to
preserving and fostering magical
practices rooted in Pakistani folklore
and Sufi mysticism it actively engages
in promoting magical education
Interfaith collaboration and the
preservation of endangered magical
creatures found in the region Spanish
Ministry of Magic the Spanish Ministry
of magic nestled in the heart of Madrid
celebrates the vibrant magical culture
and diverse Regional magical Traditions
found throughout Spain the ministry is
known for its passionate Flamenco
inspired magical performances and
renowned dueling acmy it places great
importance on upholding magical law and
ensuring the harmonious integration of
magic into Spanish Society the ministry
also actively supports the preservation
of magical artifacts and the
conservation of magical creatures unique
to the Iberian Peninsula Ugandan
Ministry of Magic the Ugandan Ministry
of magic situated in the vibrant city of
kalala showcases the country's Rich
magical Heritage and diverse Wizarding
Traditions it focuses on cultural
preservation magical creature
conservation and to the integration of
magic into traditional African practices
the ministry actively supports magical
Education and Research promoting the
development of unique magical abilities
found within the Ugandan magical
community and that about sums up the
list I'm sure there are other
governments in other Wizarding countries
but for now these are the only ones we
know about if you enjoyed this style of
video please let me know down below and
be sure to comment your video
suggestions as well also if you haven't
already be sure to go and check out the
school version of this video the history
of every Magic School in The Wizarding
World until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live